a warm welcome to this hour of news well
we begin with breaking news
Saudi Arabia's public prosecutor says
five people have been sentenced to death
in three sentenced to 24 years in prison
for the murder of Sandy journalist Jamal
khashoggi the closed-door trial was held
at the Criminal Court in the capital
Riyadh the identities of the convicted
haven't been released
Kishori was murdered in the Saudi
consulate in Istanbul last year the
crime Prince Mohammed bin Salman said he
had no prior knowledge of the operation
well Muhammad Azul is live for us and hi
there Muhammad so let's talk first of
all about the verdict what do we know
what we know is Julie that five have
been sentenced to death three would get
prison sentences so that is eight and
lives three who had been investigated by
the prosecutor and who have ceased being
cleared and they seem to be the main
people in that group that is been
suspected of killing Jamal khashoggi on
the 2nd of October 2018 when he walked
into the Saudi consulate in Istanbul but
never walked out and they are the former
high-profile adviser to the royal family
Giroud al Kitani a man considered to be
the right-hand man of president of
priests McCrone Prince Mohammed bin
Salman as well as the former deputy
intelligence chief Ahmed Al Asiri
and then also released after being
investigated by the prosecutor is the
confuse the Istanbul Saudi consulate so
those have been released so the 11-5
have gotten death sentences three prison
sentences and then the others released
that's what we know so far
Mohammed were we expecting this verdict
right now
well is it is there have been good that
side that they had put them on trial and
it was ongoing but it's almost
unexpected that it would come at this
time but there's been a lot of pressure
coming from the international community
particularly the United Nations which
has not only been talking about the need
for justice in the Jamal khashoggi
killing but also putting pressure on the
United States and the European Union to
act to see that there be justice and
there's been also a lot of pressure
coming from Turkey with its angry
president at one point starting you know
a leaking information of what they knew
about the matter and this is a matter
that has generated so much global out up
row but what we know is there's been a
lot of cover-up there's been a lot of
the lies coming from Riyadh has been so
filled that even Donald Trump who is a
swoon admirer of president of of the
countries has called it the cover the
worst cover-up ever so there's been a
lot of misinformation here and there and
very few expect that these verdict as it
is with over with the three most
important men in those 11 who had been
put on trial released will appease the
anger that the killing of that
journalist Jamal khashoggi has cost
Muhammad do you think to your point just
there that with this verdict it will
perhaps present more questions than it
answers well that is how it looks at the
moment and I think the main thing that
is going to raise a lot of eyebrows is
the release of the men who've been
considered to be leading the act of
murdering Jamal Khashoggi we're talking
about the former
high-profile advisor to the royal family
Kotani as well as ala city the deputy
intelligence chief and also the Consul
in Istanbul at the time because they
were seen as the top people within the
15 people who are believed to have been
there when Jamal khashoggi was killed
and now that they've been let off the
hook it's going to it might create more
anger supporters joining me there live
from Ankara well for more let's talk now
to mehmet gellick he joins us now from
Istanbul he's the managing editor of the
daily Sabah that's an english-language
newspaper and Mehmet very warm welcome
to the programme for a small your review
on this verdict it seems that what's
interesting about it are is more those
people who haven't been charged than
those who have you're definitely right I
think the fact that some high-profile
names have not been charged it raises
questions on credibility of the trial
itself and whether or not these people
were just picked as scapegoats so that
there is a seemingly moving forward
trial taking place and I think this you
know the results announced today shows
that it wasn't anything it hasn't been
anything more than just finding some
finds finding some names to blame the
big issue or a big big problem or a
complex murder on some names but the
fact that the console the fact that the
Kotani is is not is released i think
raised a lot of questions on the
credibility of this whole process and
whether or not the international
community will be will be convinced with
the result I think it's it's a matter
that we should look into because the top
advise one of the top a man on this
whole process
is released and I think there should be
some sort of questioning on why this
person was part of this and why this
person has not been charged with
anything and released basically there is
there has been evidence showing phone
calls between some of the people who
carried out this incident and the murder
and katana himself so there is evidence
linking all these figures that are
released with the actual event taking
place the Consul General himself for
example the fact that he's not found
guilty is I think a problematic thing
here that raises a lot of questions
about the credibility of the trial
amendment I wonder what you think the
reaction might be where you sit right
now in Turkey we know of course the
range of type order when kept the
pressure on Saudi Arabia to get answers
what do you think the reaction will be
where you are since we're talking here
about again this more questions
this raising more questions and then
answering those we already had the the
reaction from Ankara I think from the
beginning has been to seek a credible
trial and to make sure that those who
are responsible from top to the bottom
are brought to justice
and I think the decision made today
shows that the Ankara is concerned from
the beginning on the credibility of the
process were very on place so today's
decision will make Ankara again raise
these credibility issue and I think the
reaction will be will be similar to what
it has been throughout the process from
the beginning and that is the the you
know the fact that some blame is trying
to be taken from you know those on
really really top in the royal family
and responsible from this brutal murder
Ankara will still reiterate that the the
those who are responsible from on the
top the decision-makers need to brought
be brought to justice not
I mean as well as those who are who
actually committed the crime
we heard Mamet's Donald Trump say that
and he's an enum admirer of Mohammed bin
Salman say that it was the worst
cover-up ever so I'm wondering in wider
reaction from the international
community what that might be in in the
days and hours ahead
well international community has I mean
Turkey has been told basically the only
vocal voice in the international
community trying to make sure that some
steps are taken against Riyadh but
beyond some condemnation Zhai disregard
I mean I I did I don't think any of the
politicians political leaders will come
up with some concrete measures against
yet however I think in the international
community's mind being the civil society
in the international community or the
people were or the journalists in the
international community will make sure
that this process and this announcement
today find it find the right place and
the agenda of the international
community but whether or not some
concrete measures will be taken by the
world leaders I think that's something
that is still questionable because no
concrete measures have been taken
against Riyadh and and the story is
diminishing the the credibility of these
leaders when it comes to human rights
and democracy human rights and and
seeking justice for victims such as
horribly manager like they're joining me
live from Ankara sir thank you well it's
been over a year since journalists and
u.s. resident Jamal khashoggi was killed
it happened on October the 2nd 2018
inside the Saudi consulate where he was
planning on picking up documents for his
upcoming wedding turkey officials said a
hit team of 15 Saudis was sent Istanbul
to carry out the murder at least three
key players were removed from their
high-level post in connection to the
case
they
two days I would are Kotani one so top
aide to crime Prince Mohammed bin Salman
he's believed to have overseen the
murder whilst giving orders over Skype
now the prosecutor says he was
investigated but not charged and was
released
sadly prosecutors had blamed deputy
intelligence chief ahmed al Asiri for
coordinating the killing but the
prosecutor says he was released for
insufficient evidence for the residents
of the Saudi Consul General at the time
Hamid Al Fateh V is where Turkish
investigators say a Shoji's body parts
were disposed of he too has been
released by the prosecutor well let's
bring in al jazeera senior political
analyst Marwan Bashara on the line from
Doha Marwan an extraordinary verdict - a
story that really has put these
spotlights on Saudi Arabia yes
absolutely
this is he will have the fourth stage of
this of this terrible tragedy against
our colleague a journalist yamaraja g
extorted with the Saudi denial of that
anything had happened at the Saudi
consulate in Istanbul saying that they
don't know where he is and so on so
forth and then when the Turkish
authorities released what they knew
about the incident then the Saudis came
forward with some partial admission
saying rogue elements in the Saudi
intelligence have carried this affair
and then they were hoping for a total
dismissal of the entire affair you
trying to move on with all sorts of
festivities in Saudi and better
relations with the Trump administration
and so on so forth
but that did not work out very well
because of the especially media and
congressional pressure on Saudi Arabia
and as we're moving to the fourth stage
and that is some sort of a return to a
crisis management whereby the Saudis are
trying or keeping up appearances as if
they are dealing with the situation but
there are a number of problems with that
with the verdict today one the killing
of Jamaat resumed G is a pull
ethical assassination is extrajudicial
assassination killing and hence there
has to be some political
responsibilities and we all know from
the CIA in the United States to the
Special Rapporteur by the United Nations
and yes Calabar that the crown prince
has a responsibility in this issue and
we're sure since there is no judiciary
independence and Saudi Arabia that the
crown prince and his lackeys will not be
prosecuted and hence once again the
special adviser saw the Qatari and the
head of the intelligence a theory had
been released and a number of others now
are presumably going to be sentenced to
death now since those world elements of
our sentences according to the
prosecutor general did not have in his
words any enmity towards democracy then
that poses the question why would he
kill him
well the only reasonable explanation is
because they were ordered to ordered by
whom well it has to be someone in the
political a salon clearly this judiciary
process does not have that kind of
authority to investigate or to question
the likes of the crown prince and his
lackeys Marwan timing-wise why come up
with this verdict now if the
international community is simply going
to turn around and say this is just not
credible well they are but this what
what the argument is is that an
investment since the beginning when they
first partially admitted the
responsibility for the killing is that
they are trying to deal with it
internally that this is not something
that the United Nations the United
States that alone Turkey will dictate
and that it is an internal affair of
Saudi Arabia and hence the judiciary is
taking care of it and if you remember
right after that partial admission we
entered into that phase of secret trial
in Saudi Arabia we never understood who
how and why and even
whatever foreign ambassadors that were
there did not really have much access
into what was going on and now as a
fashion because of the continued
pressure are coming out of the United
States and other Western allies of Saudi
Arabia and because of the pressure
coming out of Turkey this issue could
not just be washed away could not be
simply you know sort of pushed under the
carpet they had to come up with some
kind of answers and here we are in this
phase that they're saying they're raw
elements and we are prosecuting the
wrong elements but as I said this is a
political extrajudicial killing and
there is a political responsibilities
but you cannot expect in Saudi Arabia
where there is no independent judiciary
for this thing to take place that's why
this issue knees internationalization
this issue needs the United Nations and
other to get involved it at least needs
some kind of an independent prosecutor
of sort who that will be able to look at
the political implications of the Saudi
leadership in it but for the time being
the Saudis are trying to provide some
answers partial some of them even
one-headed answers in order to on your
question to your guests and I think this
is the most important question will this
do my guess is it will not do my guess
is that the Saudis are trying within the
constraints of an authoritarian regime
to provide some answers and I think
these answers will prove for the falling
short of what the international
community expects on this issue one
Bashara joining me there Marwan Sankey